hello my name is dr whitney holden and i
have a phd in microbiology and
immunology i teach biology and research
at asmsa
because of my background as a researcher
i'm always looking for new innovations
to test in my classroom
i use technologies like quizlet live
paradigm a variety of podcasts
hhmi biointeractive and more in the past
five years i've used four different
learning management systems and five
different approaches to labs for remote
students at various schools i work with
including filming my own virtual labs
for them to share online resources with
other educators i serve on merlot's
international biology editorial board
where i help to curate the life science
oer collection
i also teach an independent research
capstone course this class is about so
much more than just competing in science
fair i develop well-rounded
scientifically literate students by
focusing on statistical analysis and
peer-reviewed scientific literature
i'm even working with my most recent
isaf finalists to submit their research
for publication to international student
journals i also co-direct
two major outreach programs the first is
advanced biology plus
where i provide curriculum and training
to dozens of arkansas ap biology
classrooms
participating schools have gone from
only 10 percent of their students
passing the ap biology exam to 40
percent of their students passing that
exam
the second program is the arkansas
summer research institute which is for
underrepresented students in stem
they learn technical skills like
electrophoresis and cad and 3d printing
while also focusing on essential
professional skills things like resumes
entrepreneurship networking and more i
even run a youtube channel called
biology professor with 40
000 subscribers and almost 4
million views from virtually every
country in the world through my work i
have found
the keys to building truly innovative
experiences
are mentorship teamwork respect
and a willingness to challenge myself as
well as my students
thank you